hello everyone and welcome to another
video now about six months ago we looked
at the Intel Arc A380 the cheapest of
the currently available Arc cards just
like with the more powerful a750 I plan
to revisit it after multiple driver
updates and today is that day the six
gigabyte Arc A380 has dropped in price
but it's still quite a hard sell
considering that plenty of more powerful
used Market options have dropped in
price with it the Reliance of resizable
bar support for best performance means
that one of these is still best suited
to a more modern build with that said if
you are looking for something new either
as a cheap addition to a budget setup or
you aren't interested in higher than
1080p gaming then the A380 is better now
than it's ever been it's still not
perfect but Intel's dedication to these
art cards is clear and evidenced by the
regular driver updates let's look at
some comparative results to my initial
testing to begin with which was
conducted almost six months ago to the
day I'm using in the latest beta driver
release at the time of this video which
is the version ending in dot 4335
Spider-Man is up first and at low we are
getting over 60 FPS on average with
solid percentile lows six months ago
when the card had been on the market for
what I think was about half a year we
were seeing just 49 FPS at the time this
felt fine and I'd still consider it
playable but this sort of difference is
very nice to see there are improvements
to the percentile figures as well as I
said before there are better used
options for similar money but it's
always nice to see progress being made
with these new cards another noticeable
gaming difference was with cyberpunk
which is now playing at closer to 60 FPS
of course the game itself may have seen
some performance improvements over the
last half a year anyway but I've not
seen changes like this on any of my
other Hardware so I think it's clear
that the drivers play a big part here I
haven't enabled any upscaling either now
you could for sure if you want at least
60 FPS more of the time but the settings
I've gone for at Native resolution feel
very playable and again it's nice to see
the uplift I think the six gigs of vram
definitely helps the A380 out in
comparison to other low-cost competitors
Red Dead Redemption 2 now sits at closer
to 60fps on average with increased
percentile figures the 0.1 percent low
could still use some work but there
aren't as many little dips and drops in
and around the busier towns hopefully
this trend continues but I'm not sure
how much more performance Intel can
squeeze out of this budget card if you
want an Intel card but also want
guaranteed higher frames then the a750
should be up for consideration as well
all of these art cards have benefited
from additional performance over the
last few months but I think it's at the
lower end where these differences are
always more noticeable and perhaps more
appreciated before we test more games I
have one last comparison which is Eldon
ring It's always important to document
the full story and sometimes times
driver updates won't always make a big
difference six months ago the A380
struggled a little bit at medium
settings and it still isn't perfect
performance overall is better and even
the percentile lows are quite good it's
just that we are still best suited to
low with this card ideally not much of a
difference across all the figures for
Eldon ring here now though let's test a
few more tire tools Hogwarts Legacy
plays fine at low settings with Native
1080p there have been some improvements
thanks to various patches here as the
game isn't the stuttery mess it was on
launch day there are a few little
problems remaining for sure but it's not
that bad at all if you want to push the
settings a bit higher and still retain a
similar level of performance than
enabling Intel X ESS upscaling will do
the trick I set this to Quality mode and
expected a blurry mess but honestly it
still looks really sharp the average
frame rate is slightly higher too with
the settings and the game doesn't look
much worse for it as solution wise we're
still benefiting from the added visual
effects that the medium quality settings
bring to the table next up it's the
Resident Evil 4 demo with Native
resolution and the prioritized
performance preset the A380 manages 57
FPS this is of course with FSR disabled
this preset will actually enable it by
default but the game runs fine without
there will be some areas that shoot way
above 60 as well now of course if we
enable FSR this does help and we don't
need to set it to Performance or Ultra
performance quality mode will do just
fine and it will increase our frame rate
to 72 with enhanced percentile lows the
A380 is definitely more of a contender
than it was in mid-2022 but as I said
before consider all your options and
remember that I have resizable bar
enabled which will help massively I
don't think any upscaling was needed in
Forza Horizon 5. this ran with well over
60 FPS anyway at medium settings well
while high settings probably are doable
the medium preset ensures that even the
percentile lows stay above 60. you'll
see things dip a little bit in busier
areas and races but overall there are no
issues here and the game looks good you
may have noticed the car's power
consumption too it's usually anywhere
around 50 to 55 watts and when under
load this ASRock card is also very quiet
it does have an 8-pin connector which
seems unnecessary but it should work on
even some of those questionable power
supply units on the market now that
isn't a recommendation by any means just
an assumption for Warzone 2 I went with
the basic preset you can turn things up
a bit and enable xcss upscaling here but
I think that this lower preset makes
more sense because the percentile lows
stay more solid turning things up and
enabling upscaling will improve the
average but at 1.1 numbers will suffer
and that's probably not ideal in a
fast-paced online game like this just a
personal preference of course but this
is how I keep things I might consider
dropping the resolution scaling a little
bit not so much just to make it
impossible to see enemy players but
perhaps down to 90 just to increase all
the performance metrics The Witcher 3
also has upscaling options available but
I stuck with Native and opted for the
medium settings while keeping T AAU and
ssao switched on as well not only has
the cards seen some improvements but
this game has as well thanks to patches
for the next gem release which
admittedly did release in a bit of a bad
way I think that's a fair assessment now
though even busier areas will remain
steady performance wise and the A380 is
offering up surprising results
surprising all round so far actually but
let's test some really demanding games
now I guess well you could say demanding
or perhaps games that are in need of
further optimization the first of which
is Star Wars this has apparently had a
patch to improve performance I think I
read an article that that was the case
somewhere but either way it's safe to
assume that you should forget about
60fps unless you want some major
sacrifices Graphics wise but to be
honest I didn't expect to be able to hit
that anyway what I did want do was find
settings that were combine performance
and visual quality without sacrificing
too much of either I think I did that
here with the medium preset and balanced
FSR this was better than I expected in
the end but it's still early days for
this game we might see more performance
improvements as time goes on the Last of
Us is last this one started off quite
messy even though I waited for these
shaders to build it still seemed like
something was loading after I jumped
into the game because it was a bit of a
laggy mess after playing for a few
minutes however it did smooth out and
the average along with the percentile
numbers got better but we've had to
pretty much bottom out the visual
quality settings here and it does look
quite bad now overall the rk380 has seen
some big improvements thanks to Intel's
dedication to driver support it still
isn't necessarily a card I'd buy as a
primary gaming card as much as it is one
that I'd buy just to have some
occasional fun with every so often it's
exciting to plug it back into the pcie
slot and see things have improved it's
getting cheaper and cheaper as time goes
on and it seems to be available at quite
a few retailers now for just over 100
pounds or dollars I think we'll have to
do some comparisons to other low-cost
options but as time goes on the arc is
getting better I'm not sure it's getting
better at the same rate as game
optimization seems to be getting worse
so that may hinder it going forward but
that isn't the thought of the card after
all and to be honest it surprised me
today more so than it did all those
months ago when I first purchased it
thank you very much for watching then if
you enjoyed this one leave a like leave
a dislike if you didn't let me know what
you think of the arc A380 down in the
comments below subscribe to the channel
if you haven't done so already and you
want to of course and hopefully I'll see
all of you in the next one